Chicago police today fired back at
prosecutors who dropped charges against
actor Jesse Smollett this afternoon
releasing pages of evidence that led to
the original 16 charges against Smollett
correspond am at Fenway the look at the
evidence released and the ongoing fury
over the surprise dismissal of charges
today's Chicago Police released some of
its jesse small LED files before the
case was sealed documents read the ocean
Dario brothers claim they did not send
that death threat letter that police
alleged Smollett sent to himself
police say the FBI is investigating that
letter today Cook County State's
Attorney Kim Fox who recused herself
during the height of the smaller
investigation said Smollett likely would
not have gone to prison as he's a non
violent offender who forfeited his
10-thousand dollar bond and did
community service in a radio interview
Fox says I think the confusion for
people who don't understand the
intricacies of the justice system who
don't understand alternative prosecution
it's a hard thing for people to process
Fox News obtained a copy of an internal
email from Kim Fox's office requesting
examples of other cases to bolster its
stance that drop charges are not
uncommon the email reads quote nobody is
in trouble we are just looking for
further examples of how we as
prosecutors use our discretion in a way
that restores the victim but does
minimal harm to the defendant other
messages reveal Michelle Obama's former
chief of staff Tina Chen persuaded Fox
to ask the Chicago Police Superintendent
to turn his investigation over to the
FBI because the smollett family was
worried about leaks Chen message Fox
quote I wanted to give you a call on
behalf of jussie Smollett and family who
I know they have concerns about the
investigation Fox then responded spoke
to the superintendent Johnson I
convinced him to reach out to the FBI
to ask that they take over the
investigation he's reaching out now and
will get to me shortly the attorney for
the ocean Daario brothers says they were
ready to testify before the case was
dropped Fox News recently caught up with
the brothers at a boxing event
but you got a lot of fans in Chicago
what you got to say to your fans the
chicago police union has formally
requested the US Attorney's office here
in Chicago investigate Kim Fox John
the gloves are definitely off Matt fin
forced an end Chicago man thanks